[Musique]
alors ce nouveau virus c'est un
coronavirus c'est une immense famille de
virus qui en contient plusieurs
centaines on pense qu'on pensait plutôt
que la plupart de ces virus toucher les
animaux et on savait pour sûr que
jusqu'à maintenant six de ces
coronavirus était capable d'infecter
l'homme est là avec ce nouveau virus
chinois on en a découvert un septième
[Musique]
donc ce nouveau virus y peut donner des
symptômes respiratoires une fièvre une
difficulté à respirer
très proche d'une pneumonie finalement
bon moment on n'a ni vaccin ni
médicaments évidemment puisqu'on vient
de découvrir que ce virus pouvait
toucher l'homme
par contre on peut utiliser les
traitements habituels pour les symptômes
donc pour la fièvre pour les difficultés
respiratoires etc
certains patients on guérit spontanément
et ont déjà quitté l'hôpital mais
d'autres ont eu de graves complications
notamment les personnes âgées les
personnes fragiles donc qui ont des
comorbidités c'est à dire qu'ils ont
d'autres maladies et certaines personnes
sont décédées
alors les autorités sanitaires chinoises
pense qu'il viendrait d'un marché à
fruits de mer et à poissons a one
justement puisque tous les premiers
patients en tout cas la plupart la
grande majorité travaillaient travail
sur ce marché qui a été depuis fermé le
1er janvier mis en quarantaine et sur ce
marché il y avait également des animaux
morts ou vivants
or on sait que ces virus c'est corona
virus infecte principalement les
mammifères ainsi leur réservoir naturel
on va dire est qu'ils peuvent passer de
l'animal chez l'homme parce qu'ils ont
cette capacité à muter très rapidement
et une fois chez l'homme ils ont aussi
cette capacité à s'adapter à ce nouvel
hôte est finalement peut-être à se
transmettre plus facilement dom
[Musique]
il ya un parallèle à établir avec le
strass qui est pareil
idem un coronavirus et ce virus était
avait lui aussi été découvert en chine
on savait qu'il infectait des mammifères
ils n'avaient encore jamais infecter
l'homme et celui là on a identifié sa
source
il proviendrait de civette donc c'est
des petits animaux à mi-chemin pardon
entre le chat et le [ __ ] laveur on va
dire dont la viande est très très
appréciés des chinois et on pense
justement fin on est certain maintenant
que c'est cet animal là qui a transmis
le virus à des hommes des êtres humains
au chili alors le strass n'était pas
énormément contagieux comme peut l'être
le virus ebola
néanmoins il s'était quand même répandu
au total 8000 100 patients lui 1100
personnes infectées et 774 personnes
avaient trouvé la mort en chine mais
aussi dans d'autres pays asiatiques et
en france il y avait une personne trois
personnes pardon qui avaient été
infectés
le strass il avait fait beaucoup de
victimes mais il avait été facilement
endiguée à partir du moment où toutes
les mesures d'hygiène et de sécurité
avaient été prises notamment aux
aéroports et finalement l'épidémie
s'était arrêtée sans vaccin sans
médicaments simplement avec des mesures
d'hygiène comme le port d'un masque ou
le lavage des mains
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]